my guest tonight is the star and
co-creator of Comedy Central's key and
Peele
he's also the host of brain games which
will be streaming on Disney Plus on
April 17th please welcome keegan-michael
key
how you doing I'm great buddy how are
you doing I'm all right we're here in in
quarantine ah you know what I'm loving
about doing shows in quarantine I'm
seeing everyone's apartment I'm seeing
everything you know what you need you
need art behind you I need art I made
art I want to ask you about this because
this concerns me as well I have a
birthday coming up soon mm-hmm you just
celebrated a birthday in quarantine yes
tell me what it's like what can I expect
my birthday was actually lovely my wife
did a really wonderful thing for me I
woke up in the like and this is right
kind of around the beginning of all this
right so we know knowing winters she had
planned something and what and so we
were doing we woke up in the morning and
L goes l she leans over and she goes hey
I just want to show you something I was
like oh yeah so she gets her iPad she
and she turns on her iPad and there's a
video from my father-in-law and my
father-in-law my father-in-law is a TSA
agent oh really
his name is Paul his name's Paul
AZ he's 78 years old and we think we're
not sure but we're pretty sure he's the
oldest TSA agent in America I would
guess 70s si si so my father-in-law
makes this video for me and it's a
sketch he wrote a sketch with him and
his wife so I wrote this sketch he's the
guy going through security his wife
Nancy is she's wearing a sweet little
hat like I think was a homeland security
yeah but you know okay we'll give him an
A for ever and so they're doing the
sketch and she's grabbing she's grabbing
things out of a suitcase and she's like
sir may I search your bag and my father
lost doing you know your kind of your
requisite airport security jokes that
wasn't my bag I just picked that up on
the side of the road
and so she's taking water bottles out of
the bag each water bottle is completely
full and she goes this is okay it's okay
you know and she does five so threes and
five so they're learning common five and
then she pulls out a machete because
this is okay this is definitely okay
Florida pretty decent sketch he's
protesting he's protesting and then she
pulls out a piece of paper of the
business
happy birthday key and she goes now this
is not okay so make sure it doesn't
happen again next year and then very
good blow a good one you know what I
wrote sketches you know four years you
wrote sketches for yours I could never
come up with an ending they these two
amateurs came up with an ending so on
your birthday did you hear from anybody
else besides in here was the good thing
and the great thing about my birthday's
right after my father law that night
then I watched a message from my
mother-in-law then I watched a message
from my 83 year old aunts
then I watched the message from cousins
and then and then all of a sudden there
were more messages that were starting to
come from friends and then I'm going so
my wife had collected 75 birthday
greetings for me 7550 fun so we sat in
front of the iPad for an hour and 10
minutes
and watched all these wonderful like who
for example so like like like Dave
Matthews Drew Brees
Michael Strahan trying to send a message
that one Diddy Kimmel Kimmel did send
America I do have to tell you that those
a Kimmel birthday greeting comes
standard with any iPhone or flip phone
Samsung one yeah and if you get a pager
they'll write their on a page or on a
page
he makes money the guy's a genius that's
fantastic you know I wish you had
reached out to me no one reached out to
me oh well you know the thing is the
thing is I don't I don't have your phone
number
oh right you know why cuz you're never
gonna have my phone I have another
question for you which is are you
learning a lot about yourself this is
what I'm hearing from people being a
team and being sequestered and being
alone and spending a lot of time
isolated and learning about myself what
have you learned about yourself I have
learned I have learned that I have
learned that I'm a close talker
I woke talker I did not realize I was
that much of a close talker because now
with social distancing I realized that
as I'm speaking to people I'm kind of
like approaching them I was like mildly
aware of and now I'm just like Keegan
relax you have 7 years of professional
acting training they taught you how to
project they got it they can hear you
and so that's like what does he is he a
tractor beam what's wrong with you why
am I you know my son who's 14 it keeps
giving me because he notices that
when I talk in this situation if I talk
talk on a virtual call a zoom or a Skype
that I talk as if I'm talking into a
Nordic telephone you know I do worry
about you because I know we've talked
about this you're a huge sports fan yes
I am massive sports fan and sports
sports are gone right now there are no
sports what are you doing
how are you getting your fix here's
okay here's what I'm doing here's an m3
Connie I'm what I'm doing is I'm trying
to fill in the gaps of my sports
knowledge right so it's going anywhere
from okay you know the 90s like late 80s
90s early 90s NFL not my strong suit
for whatever that sports trivia game
just falls in my lap I want to be ready
you know if you're gonna do HQ online or
something like that so right before the
Dallas Cowboys dynasty in the mid
nineties I'm a little axe so pretty much
goes from the Pittsburgh Steelers to the
Cowboys I'm gonna film in that spot and
then yeah right and then in 2000 2008 I
have another gap so I'm gonna fill those
gaps in then the other thing I've been
doing is I'm brushing up on those nice
obscure sports just in case the Tokyo
Olympics happens I want to beat up on
the bad men also also it helps me when I
make a big international action movie
and I have to go to Malaysia I'm gonna
be able to go hey guys how about that
how about that doubles championship with
[Laughter]
the Malaysian you know are you are you
catching up on TV and movies that's what
a lot of people are doing we're catching
up on stuff we haven't seen I am I am
we're more right now more movies than TV
I'm one of these guys I just I don't
know how it came about but it happened
that pretty much between 1985 and 1996
or 97 I saw four mainstream movies
that's it that was it the kids I was
like hanging out with the artsy kids so
you'd come like you come to high school
and I'm going hey guys I hit that double
feature this weekend of Unbearable
Lightness of being in my beautiful
laundrette
[Laughter]
hey guys no spoilers on wait nail and I
[Music]
yeah I could see that so so I had not
seen I had not seen dirty dancing I not
seen I had not seen like even even like
kind of Main Street had not seen
analyzed this crystal I loved in Europe
had not seen Titanic had not seen you
hadn't seen Titanic No hadn't seen
everybody's beam tight how can you avoid
Titanic gates they put it on contact
lenses right there's no way to not see
Titanic I just say I was doing a lot of
theater at that time yes one of those
things we wouldn't be watching the
classics and it's been really great
we've been so now is the time for me to
catch up on those movies literally jokes
people have been telling for 25 years
and I don't get them yeah but now you're
starting to get it I'm now starting to
understand like it's it's it's helpful
to watch things like it's helpful to
watch something like American Pie and go
okay I see how come shifting and why
that's important in in that particular
genre I like I get it so it's been it's
been fascinating
so you finally understand the importance
of the shift to cinema about having sex
with pies right very very important
sub-genre also it's it's been great
because it's you know being on lockdown
with a writer director isn't boring so
we have fun so we've been we've been
we've been doing these things where Oh
so the other night I saw Air Force One
for the first time and then L had to go
do something and so when the movie was
over she came up to me she goes so tell
me how did the part of the movie and
she'd seen it and so I kind of just kind
of recap the last I don't know hour of
the movie in like 30 seconds and then
she was and then she was and she went
wait a second she said if I if I picked
another movie and we were watching
aliens she goes could you she goes could
you recap aliens in one minute
in one minute and so we were like can we
do that so
then we started thinking about what
would it be like to make a 100 could you
knock a movie down to one minute you put
it online we did we did we put that like
people are really loving this will show
a clip of it right now cuz it's really
cool let's take a look at this this is
an alien it's a movie in a minute aliens
where's everybody there's a little girl
who escaped underdog this woman she
gotta catch will you is there any other
one that you're thinking of doing movie
in a minute I mean there's some that
have come to mind and and but uh trying
to think I mean guess we're having I
mean I could probably do I could
probably do like like a rough Titanic
Titanic you want to give us just a taste
of it I won't hold you to the whole
exact minute thing you know okay oh I
think I should be able to do it though
let me see if I can let me see if I can
no pressure
don't want to pressure you during this
time of quarantine camera all right here
actually hold on you get you prepare
yourself mentally yeah it's a three hour
and 10 minute movie I believe 3:10 okay
and we need to see it in a minute and
you tell me when you're ready to go I'll
give you an action
[Music]
[Applause]
that's crazy
look at that late so you got it in
exactly one minute it was three second
literally once you were done I pulled it
in and then I hit stop so that's
probably one minute one question is that
was fantastic that was great and now I
never have to see Titanic again everyone
should be that's that's hilarious
that's really hilarious and also oddly
satisfying I have to I don't know why
but it's so satisfying to see it all
come together like that this much
together it's plenty um CliffsNotes just
made me think because brain games is
coming yeah yeah and I got to say I feel
like if you sit down with your kid and
you watch brain games that should go to
science credit for their oh boy this one
Y dimension I'm a big fan of I've never
achieved it myself but I love it when
something can be entertaining and
actually without you
even realizing it your intelligence
grows as your that's it that's such a
hard combination to hit and that's why I
really want to get the word out on brain
games brain games is gonna be available
for streaming on Disney Plus on April
17th that's important because that's the
day before my birthday and I know a lot
of presents are coming my way
keegan-michael key thank you so much
it's a pleasure always a pleasure to be
with you